my friends please if there is any clip
from this show that you've ever taken or
made take this one
and when we put up on youtube take share
it with everybody okay um
it was not even that long ago we were we
were told consistently i mean the
election was was yeah you know not even
a year ago voter id is racist yes now we
know for a fact the black community is
the least vaccinated uh demographic in
new york and they are saying yes to
mandating ids for these people this let
me explain to you to everybody why i'm
saying this is the clip you want to
share please explain to me how voter id
is racist
but mandating an id to enter an
establishment is not racist all within
the span of only a few months they
changed their argument are they what are
they going to say well voting is more
important eating isn't
sorry you don't get to go to a
supermarket eating's not important but
there won't be an argument there'll just
be a command and as you found out with
your phone calls people many many people
will just simply all of them and it you
know if half the people just said
yeah de blasio can't arrest all of us
you come in i'm gonna i'm gonna feed you
i don't care you you you do what you
think is right and then you come on in
well some people did point out fairly
that
by making the phone calls they're almost
always gonna say yes because you could
be from the city well that is that is
true now that fair but however however i
i disagree with that argument in the
sense that anybody walking in could be
from the city
that is and that's true and uh and there
will be and i would argue that the phone
call is actually better because
they could always argue oh no we always
mended you know we could say what
everyone over the phone but that's not
actually part of the violation it's
whether you come in or not yeah and so i
would actually argue that the phone
you're more likely to get the truth if
somebody walks in they're gonna be like
i'm not i don't know i don't know who
you are i don't care you could be from
the city if someone calls they're like
no
who cares what are you gonna do i'm not
gonna get a fine for telling you yes or
no
you know but they just take it and
they're gonna go vote for another
democrat
yeah you know um
well your own hell these are people who
just said they were they were they're
like we're just following orders it's
it's we're just following the mayor's
orders we're just following orders if
someone goes in and they're not
vaccinated and they like go into a
restaurant they get found out that they
were like you can't even go in what well
if they make it in with like a fake
passport or something they said it's
fraud so they'll go to jail where they
could infect other prisoners with kovitz
no no no no no no no no no they've
released all those prisoners oh yeah now
if you hit an asian
elderly woman on the head with a hammer
you will be released on your own
recognizance that happened
that happens a lot that's a problem but
if you go into a restaurant and pretend
to be vaccinated when you aren't
even though you don't have covet and
you're not spreading disease
you you will be prosecuted as i
understand it because that's justice of
some sort in some way and i i have to
say i'm i'm a little confused
i'm not confused it's all a lie it's all
a scam
it's all a garbage establishment
that has failed in everything it's done
for the last 30 years
every single thing i mean you look at it
and i said before said again i'll say it
again
you look at the establishment and the
people who ran the institutions in the
40s and won world war ii
they beat the depression 60s they put a
man on the moon they did civil rights
they changed our country in an important
way those are huge achievements in the
80s we brought the economy roaring back
we destroyed the evil empire and then
look at this establishment look at the
people we have now they've given us wall
street they've given us cobble they've
given us grinder
they're so rich too and they're oh my
god they make so much money relative to
these people that are suffering yes like
and and these people keep voting for i'm
not a crazy marxist where it's like the
rich the we must the class war like
there is a class there's a this you know
there's a problem it's all about class
why do you think bush and obama and
clinton are all palin around with each
other you know you see the footage when
they're together and they're all hugging
and kissing
i thought they hated each other i was
informed that they're they're they're
some are against us and some are for us
but no they're all for each other i hate
this marxist analysis crap where class
is important but dude class is important
and they stick together that's why you
see republicans voting for this idiotic
uh
uh
alleged infrastructure thing that's why
you see the uniparty in washington
working together because they all sit
together at the same clubs and there was
even some mainstream media saying that
joe biden should have stayed in
afghanistan that he should not have
withdrawn that
uh he made a terrible mistake because he
should have taken the other options of
remaining
they they want the war
they want military intervention they
want conflict it's republicans and
democrats they were the architects of
the whole thing for the past 20 years
and what happened is in 2016 two
insurgent candidates emerged bernie
sanders and donald trump bernie is too
weak to get the door open donald trump
was a bull charging through the door and
he got into the republican party but he
is not a republican and boy were they
pissed oh they were furious they were
furious they
they can't afford to allow their
weaknesses to be exposed and he exposed
them
and and he was one of them look
trump wanted to be an elite guy he liked
to party with those guys he he would
give uh uh interviews to maggie haberman
right he still gives interviews to bob
woodward look i write for town
we've been very nice to donald trump and
very you know we point out a lot of good
things he's done he doesn't sit down
with us
i'm wondering when we're going to see
trump and biden
shaking hands and high-fiving uh i i
don't think he's quite there because
he's six years he's the designated
emmanuel goldstein i don't i don't think
that'll happen he's a class
though he is part of that class he's
prodigal bush who remember chimpy
mchitler halliburton
horrible worst guy in the world went out
you know he and he's giggling with uh
what's her name
ellen yeah yeah he paints sharing
candies yeah
i'm going to paint another picture of
one of the veterans i made
look
that
the the strategy in
afghanistan has got to be get out that
doesn't justify tactics that lead to
this abortion that we've been watching
over the last two days i gotta it didn't
have to be this so you're retired
colonel
colonel i did not serve in afghanistan
i'm just a war college graduate the
party war college the army war college
but um so i'm looking at it out as an
outside observer so i'm not gonna come
well you know when i was uh sitting
insurance with pashtun warrior that
wasn't me okay but from a disliking
space but so but we'll get in a second
yeah i want to focus on uh
the people who voted for this
who who believed that
you know i'll put it this way joe biden
saying i inherited this deal from trump
wasn't joe biden running for president
when trump was making the deal and he
knew what he was voting to be in charge
of they both share the strategy which
was get out of afghanistan a strategy i
share
this simple that
i did
i i did a thread on twitter about this
there's three ways you end a war you win
it you'll lose it or you negotiate it
out
we aren't going to win it we've decided
that as a people because to win it
requires you essentially i have to do
what the british did to the boars and
the boer war which is take everyone from
the countryside stick them in australian
fun camps
right alternative quarantine alternative
coordinating things where you keep them
where where the the
and then everybody outside who's not in
a camp you kill okay so you mix the boar
war with the uh with the classic roman
technique uh you put everybody in a camp
and then kill everybody else we're not
willing to do that good okay great i i i
i don't think liz i don't
look i don't have a problem with a
punitive expedition that was another
thing the romans would do the germans
have come across the rhine pillage and
gull for a while go back and then a
couple legions would go out pillage in
germany for a while and then the germans
would be cool for 20 years
punitive expedition you let them launch
from a 911 from your country we're going
to go in and we're going to lay some
waste to it we're going to kill those
guys we're going to give you a pain in
the ass then we're going to leave
and that's fine instead somewhere along
the way they said you know what
let's turn
these mountain tribesmen into a bunch of
vermonters and they'll have their little
city councils and they'll have nice
clean uh elections and they'll have
little little green little commons in
the middle of their villages and
everything will be groovy
they didn't want that
yeah and they weren't going to do that
and that's why probably the taliban's
numbers began to swell substantially the
past decade from estimates of like
twenty thousand to two hundred thousand
well
i mean we were the outsiders and we were
changing their culture we went over
there and said you know what's important
validating the trans experience
there is uh this violence they're not
into that there's a viral photo showing
the global the un global agenda was it
the 2030 or whatever and it's got all
it's got the wheel with all the colors
and it's like gender equality and all
these things and there's a photo of a
taliban guy holding a gun and pointing
at a bunch of civilians
this idea
how how how absolutely psychotic are
these people at the u.n to be like you
can go in
make demands of a culture without
changing the culture
what the were they thinking to just go
into this country and be like these
people hate us they don't know us they
don't like us they don't share our ways
but we can just put up this billboard
and tell them that's how you're living
now on and they'll accept they're like
enacting ancient military strategy like
how you remember the um the in the
revolutionary war the british would walk
in lines they would like old school
they'd line up and they'd all walk
forward together and the americans were
hiding behind trees and they would just
mow them down world war one they would
walk in lines towards the machine gun
turrets you have to evolve your strategy
now with social media and internet you
can't just put up a billboard and expect
the dumb ignorant surroundings
well here's the thing
the west is exhausted morally it no
longer believes in itself it's no longer
assertive and strong uh uh you know 150
years ago you know the brits were all
you know the europeans were all we're
going to colonize because we're the best
now they're they're all elderly they're
exhausted they're watching their uh euro
they're you know they're watching uh
finland's uh edm group sing on
eurovision okay you know as they
anesthetize themselves with their
terrible music and crappy food uh and
and basically wait childless to die
the
the taliban on the other hand believe in
something what they believe in is
terrible and evil
all right they're they're bad people
yeah
but they believe in something and the
power of belief the power of commitment
will eventually overtake
you know
the the the kind of empty ideology of
people who hire a few warriors to go out
and fight and look our our volunteer
army was a great art we we fought
tactically on the ground
man-to-man magnificently our guys are
very brave and shouldn't be uh and
should be proud that they serve their
country
that being said
they were put in the service of a
mission that was ridiculous and
certainly not for their own interests
what's what we're seeing with
afghanistan in my opinion is
look whether you liked it or not america
engaged in foreign excursions
military-based all over the world and
now we have this major failure happening
in afghanistan just another grain of
sand in the heap of u.s power influence
faltering yes thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you